πως νιώθεται που σε μερικές εβδομάδες ολοκριώνεται μια διαδρομή πέντετών σαν επίτροπος εσθάνομε ότι έδωσα
ότι μπορούσα το καλύτερο για για τον τόπο μου είναι στις σκέψεις της κυρίας τνας
κυριακή του του ενδεχούμενο να κατέβει για πρόεδρος της δημοκράτίας αναλάβατει σαν επίτροπος και μετά
πολύ κες εβδομάδες ξεσπαεπανδημία του κορονογίου τη θύμαστε από κινη την περίομια βεβαιότητα ήταν μια
πρωτογνωρή κρίση ηκύρθαν στιγμες που ι στενακριακήδου φοβήθηκε για όλα αυτά όχι καποία χώρα δεν
είδαν προετιμασμένη η πολιτική τελειώνι για την στεακυριακήεσείς πως το αντιμετωπίστο όπως όλι άλλη άνθρωποι
που έρχονται αντημέτωπε με μιαδιάγνωση με τη λέξη καρκίνους από την αρχή η ξέρε ότι
ήταν μονόδρομος ότι έπρεπε να το αντιμετωπίσω πιστευότι καμία γυναίκα και κανένας ασθενής δεν πρέπει
να εσθάνεται μόνο του να ευνιώθει τη πάντα υπάρχει αναχαίρι του μποεύ να τον κρατήουλες
τε φίλε καλώς ορίς σαςσ ένα ακόμη αντέναλλα εκπότας η διαίτερη τη τιμή σήμερα αφού
μαζί μας είναι μια κυρία της πολιτικής κια την οποία δεν θα βρις κανένα ναπει
κάτι κακό μια κυρία με πλούσια δράση και σε μια από τις τελευταίς τησης ως
συνεντεύξης σαν επίτροπος της ευρωπαϊκής ε ενώτησε ότι αφρά την υγεία και την ασφάλεια τροφήμον
η κυρία στελα κυριακήδου καια κυριακήδου υχαριστώ πολύ για την τιμή να στα σήμερα στο
πότκας εγώ ευχαριστώ πάρα πολύ για την πρόσκληση σε ένα από τα λίγα πότκα στα
οποία έχεται κάνει αυτά τα πέντε χρόνια ναι σαν από τα πολύ λίγα πότασ που
που έχω κάνει αυτά τα πέντε χρόνια λά πραγματικά ήταν με διαίτερη χαρα απου ανταποκρίθηκα
στην πρόσκλησή σας διώτη μου δίνεται και μια ευκαιρί έτσι να μυραστώ κάποια κάποιες σκέψεις
κάποια θέματα τα οτα οποία έχουμε